but you see you can't tell people that
and just by telling get them to see it
just in in exactly this way you people
who know that the earth is flat
can't be reasoned with people who
believe that the bible is the literal
word of god
absolutely impossible to reason with
them at all because they know it is so
so in the same way
we tend to know
that we are all separate poor little me
and that we are in need of salvation or
something
and we know this is so and so somebody
says well you are not really that you
know that that feeling of separateness
is an illusion
well it's all very nice in theory but i
don't feel it
so what will you do what will you do
with the person
who is convinced that the earth is flat
no way of reasoning with them
if it's for some reason important that
he discovered that the earth is round
you've got to play a game with him you
want to play a trick on him
you tell him great the earth is flat
let's go and look over the edge wouldn't
that be fun
of course if we're going to look over
the edge of the earth we must be very
very careful that
we don't go around in circles or we'll
never get to the edge
so we've got to go along consistently
along a certain line of latitude
westwards
and then we're going to come to the edge
of the earth just so long as we're
consistent
in other words in order to convince a
flat artist
that the world is round you've got to
make him act
consistently on his own proposition
and go consistently westwards to find
the edge of the world
now at last when he by going
consistently westwards he comes back to
the place where he started
he's been convinced that the earth is at
least cylindrical
and he may believe you then take it on
faith that if he goes along a line of
longitude
the same thing will happen
but you see what you did was to make him
persist in his folly
now that's the whole method of zen
to make people
become perfect
egotists